this is my air fried honey garlic wings
and they are bursting with flavors sweet
sticky Savory Umami it is just so good
but the best part about it it's so easy
to make let's get into it first things
first once your chicken has been washed
and dried and separate them and from
there add some oil and season with the
following spices for crispy air fried
chicken the key is baking powder
from there go ahead and mix everything
up evenly of course into airfryer goes
the amount of time will be on the screen
make sure you flip it halfway now for
the sauce combine butter minced garlic
soy sauce come in with some honey and
that makes it some nice and bubbly
finally we're going to add our crispy
Wings to the Bowl pour that sauce on top
give them a nice mix hit it with parsley
because of fancy folks I'm telling you
this is it enjoy